die original münchner weißwurst kommt in
einer terrine mit heißem wasser auf den
tisch so ist es tradition und die wird
hier im münchner hofbräuhaus gepflegt
andreas zeller ist der hauseigene
metzger bayerischen spezialität
produktionsbeginn fünf uhr morgens auch
diesen brauch hat man sich hier bewahrt
früher wurde gleich nach der
hausschlachtung produziert als es noch
keine kühltechnik ab für die füllung das
sogenannte berät werden kalbsfleisch
kochsalz und eis schnee vermischt das
salz gibt den würsten später die weiße
farbe
ob die bindung so weit zum passt wir
haben es mit morgen gleich angefangen es
mit salz und gewürzen ersten drittels
bis auf sechs grad lassen dass seine
emotionen zusammen bringen dass die
wurst hält speckschwarte kommen hinzu
zwiebeln und petersilie die genaue
gewürzmischung ist das geheimnis von
andreas zeller etwa zwölf zentimeter
lang und rund 100 gramm schwer müssen
sie sein
20 km weißwurst produzieren sie für das
münchner hofbräuhaus pro jahr
gegart werden sie in einer dampf kammer
am marienplatz im zentrum münchens soll
die erste weißwurst gebrüht worden sein
eine zufalls erfindung am gasthaus zum
ewigen licht erinnert nur eine tafel an
den entstehungsort 1857 soll der metzger
josef moser für seine teils bratwürste
keine schaafs wärme mehr gehabt haben
so füllte er schweine dame aus angst die
haut könnte beim braten platzen da er
sie in heißem wasser
das war die geburtsstunde der münchner
weißwurst
seit diesem oktober hat die weißwurst
auch eine königin bewerbungen kamen
sogar aus china
südtirol und arabischen ländern die
krone aber bekam nadja widmann eine
echte bayern die weißwurst ist
weltberühmt und für viele ausländer
sinnbild deutscher esskultur wie sie
allerdings verzerrt wird wissen nur
wenige
die weißwurst ist ein bayerisches
frühstück stimmt ja man darf die pelle
nicht essen
man ist sie immer mit einem bier und
einer brezel einfach essen einfach mit
einer gabel essen das ist alles zurück
im münchner hofbräuhaus treffpunkt für
gäste aus aller welt ein klassiker auf
der speisekarte
das weißwurstfrühstück dabei gibt es
einiges zu beachten
verzerrt werden soll die weißwurst vor
12 uhr wie das ist eine wissenschaft für
sich
traditionsbewusste bayern wie dieser
stammgast saugen die wurst aus zu zehn
wird das im bayerischen genannt der wahl
münchner werner siegert hat 2003 den
weißwurst knigge geschrieben es gibt ihn
auf japanisch und englisch chinesisch
ist geplant
ein durch leyen über sitten und unsitten
rund um den richtigen verzehr der wurst
das sind die traditionalisten
das hat ja auch eine geschichte weil das
früher auf dem jamaa keine gabel und
kaum essen gab
sie sollten denn die leute die weißwurst
essen also sie konnten nur rein weiß nun
raussaugen und dann kam die gar für
manche traditionalisten schlimme zeit
das messer und gabel dazu gelegt wurden
naja und dann können sie längst
schneiden quer schneiden kreuz schnitt
machen
auf diese technik schwört werner siegert
mundgerechte häppchen den worten formen
dazu süßer senf brezen und weißbier
pflicht für ein richtiges
weißwurstfrühstück
ich kann die anderen die quer schneiden
oder
längst nein nur bedauern dass sie diese
kunst nicht kennen
egal mit welcher technik gegessen wird
die münchner weißwurst ist kult ein
stück bayerische lebenskultur und ein
mythos über die grenzen deutschlands
hinaus